et retour à une vie normale en russie
après une semaine chauvin dans tout le
pays pour enrayer la propagation
d'épidémies cafés restaurants centres
sportifs notamment ou rouvert
confinement partiel levé également dans
la capitale les précisions de notre
correspondante verhaeghe hoffman
la période chômée s'est officiellement
terminée aujourd'hui partout en russie
sauf dans cinq régions du pays qui ont
pris la décision de prolonger le
confinement moscou le foyer épidémique
principal en russie n'en fait pas partie
même si pour les autorités il est
prématuré de faire le bilan des effets
des restrictions la situation semble se
stabiliser
je propose d'écouter
il est trop tôt pour en tirer des
conclusions
la situation sera clair dans une semaine
la situation réelle
vous avez entendu la déclaration des
dirigeants des régions mais je parle
surtout des propos de sergueï sobianine
nous habitons moscou et notre mère a dit
que la situation dans la région de
moscou se stabiliser en ce qui concerne
la propagation du virus et les taux
d'incidence
en fait c'est la raison pour laquelle ce
régime des jours chômés n'a pas été
prolongé ici à moscou mais l'effet réel
sera percevable plus tard
malgré la fin de la période chômée
moscou maintient une série de
restrictions sanitaires les autorités
continuent de promouvoir à la
vaccination dont les chiffres restent à
des niveaux relativement bas dans la
capitale seuls 4,5 millions de personnes
ont reçu les deux doses sur une
population de 15 millions d'habitants
écoutez le 8 novembre moscou retrouve
son régime normal la situation
épidémique s'est stabilisé mais reste
néanmoins assez tendue dans ce contexte
les jours chômés ne seront pas prolongés
mais certaines restrictions dans la
ville resteront en vigueur pour prévenir
l'augmentation du nombre de malades
atteints du coc vite 19 en particulier
maintenu la règle exigeant qu au moins
30 % des employés des entreprises
travaillent à 10 ans notamment ceux qui
ont des maladies chroniques ou sont âgés
de plus de 60 ans les habitants de la
ville qui relèvent de ces groupes
sociaux et qui ne se sont pas fait
vacciner et n'ont pas été atteints du
coc vite 19 au cours des six derniers
mois sont obligés de rester à la maison
néanmoins les chiffres des
contaminations sont effectivement baisse
partout en russie on dénombre près de
trente neuf mille nouveaux cas de corona
virus dont près de 5000 à moscou
précédemment le pays enregistrait près
de quarante et un mille contamination
quotidienne dont près de 8000 à moscou
reste que le niveau de mortalité son
maintien à un niveau alarmant des
passants depuis presque un mois plus de
mille décès par jour